hey we're just a snippet of squanch
games and we're here to talk about high
on life our new action adventure comedy
metroidvania first person shooter
that uh is nothing at all
a little bit like microsoft excel all
right you're a bounty hunter now you've
got to help me rescue my friends they're
gatlians just like me
that's our game high on life pretty
insane uh there's a lot to talk about
let's dive in
so justin you're typically known for
working in animation what brings you
into the world of games why are you in
the world of games yeah yeah i i'm
obsessed with games
have been my whole life always had ideas
always had you know things i would love
to make but just never thought i could
ever step into that arena because i
don't i lack
i lack all the skills needed you don't
know how other than other than like
creative uh direction creative ideas
like like other than that i lack all the
skills to
execute but that's why like that's part
of why you want to start squanch right
is like to be able to have an idea like
that and let it grow to something and
and to be able to be
creatively um free i wanted to make
games that i wanted to play and that was
sort of the spark that just
lit the fire of squanch games and then
we shipped trover and we shipped
accounting plus and now we're on
this
absolutely
dream game this is like our real
legit swing at like a proper
you know like we're indie but like this
is like our triple a like yeah or is it
triple i
for indy we're triple i yeah yeah this
is a triple i game so the story of our
game mostly follows like earth being
invaded by this evil criminal cartel of
aliens who come in and kidnap humans and
start selling them on the black market
like they're drugs and you're the one
human who has to team up with a talking
gun and stop them and when you select a
cartel leader that you're gonna go after
like
it
opens the the portal door
to that world that they're in eric uh
can you tell us a little bit about the
worlds of the game the art style of the
game the visuals yeah yeah so we spent a
lot of time kind of constructing and
creating these awesome alien worlds uh
myself and uh mikey spano who is our art
director him and i worked like a ton on
the sort of art direction of the game he
really kind of landed in this space
which was kind of
blade runner meets the muppets so we're
trying to capture that feeling with all
of our characters especially our aliens
uh and then each world has its own kind
of unique flavor right i think some of
the ideas came from very kind of core
thoughts like we're like we want to have
an awesome alien like drug dense spa on
an asteroid and yeah what makes me
really excited is the sort of really
clear
and like it's almost deceivingly simple
narrative right save the earth humans
are drugs talking guns tada so alec what
you know what who are the guns what's
their deal the guns are these talking
alien gatlians um they're all shaped
somewhat like a gun you'd find on earth
but they've evolved to be just gun-like
in their own way and so uh this race of
gatlians each has their own unique
personality their unique set of
abilities and you're going to be
rescuing them from this evil alien
cartel and together
you got to stop the bad guys you get
more gatlings yeah get more collect more
gatlins yeah a lot of players are going
to have very different experiences
depending on what gun they favor yeah
you kind of pick your favorite companion
to have that a lot and hear their
dialogue be part of different different
cut different uh dialogue scenes and
stuff yeah look at us blast in the way
and sometimes you can unlock the guns in
a different order than another player
has so when you go back through a level
you'll see things that you would have
been able to access if you've done it in
the other order
that's a huge one all right so we've
talked about this crazy good game that
sounds amazing why should people be
excited to play it as a studio we are
attempting to bring
a level
adult comedy into video games something
i love about squanch is we would put a
lot of effort into things that a lot of
other studios wouldn't even bother like
like a single small joke that five
players might find well okay well now
well now i sort of now i can i love that
stuff i love like edge casing and like
what makes you remember a game yeah like
if a player is trying to break the game
in a certain way and then you have an
answer for that for them that is like
such a memorable and amazing uh moment
it's almost like watching tv but the
viewer is able to reach into the tv and
and poke a thing and the character has
to respond to that and there's so much
fun to be had you can skip it all we
worked really hard on it if you want to
skip it yeah if you want to just like
miss out on like you know if you're like
a big dummy and you don't want to play
the game at all that's fine we're not
going to judge you we're just going to
be upset